[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
anstrengend war's aber auch schön
fakt ist
das gespenst lockdown ist zurück
und damit blüht allem wieder viel zeit
im engen familienkreis
kulturplatz mit einem aktuell besonders
mutigen gegenentwurf zur kleinfamilie
[Musik]
ein golfplatz wir machen heute station
nahe bern und versuchen eine ganz und
gar ungewöhnliche familie der musiker
christoph trummer zieht hier heute ein
mit frau und kind klingt soweit ganz
gewöhnlich aber diese wahl familie
besteht nicht aus drei menschen sondern
auch 27 wie geht familie im neuen
jahrtausend und welche bedeutung hat
dieser mikrokosmos heute überhaupt noch
für uns gerade in pandemischen zeiten
das wollen wir erforschen schön sind sie
mit dabei
[Musik]
auf die vorstellung
ja
[Musik]
richtig
und da sie bereits da und großer tisch
mit der familie trummer widmer aber groß
ist schon voller kennt diese aber unter
aktuellen stand sie möchten wir sind
doch jetzt geht ein zyklus gleichen hat
jetzt treibe mir egal ob 20 oder sollten
das öfters als großes zu haben aber ich
meine generation also michael jetzt war
vor nicht mal jahre bis ein bis kurz
über 60 es ist alles vertreten und mit
ebenso pragmatisch als logo das ist
nicht wahnsinnig progressiv sich seine
familie zusammen aber also wollen wir wo
man halt mehr regeneration und alles hat
antrages ist sie und man hilft einander
und macworld same und mann stürzte zirka
70 teilte witz schwieriger so dass die
sonne als gemeinschaftsprojekt ihr
werdet also künftig die familie habe mit
eur 3 jährige tochter unter großfamilie
michael lehner wo dann die 27 man schon
gemacht hat oder wie kann das
funktionieren mit rückzug und der
verschmelzung das architektonische
umsetzung so wohneinheiten hey wo ihr
die wohneinheit für sich hat und und
betet und das ist widerlich linz die vom
rückzug die wohneinheiten michael yani
spart nicht nur zeit gewohnt und diese
software hat das gar nicht anders muss
probiert und die glaube die die zahl
familie ist für die bettenzahl aber und
habe mich weil die beiden musiker den
musikern einen mannschaftserfolg mich am
wochenende fort man sich li na zoo was
was ist über schnitt und nicht ganz so
einfach zwar aber viel viel einfacher zu
organisieren ist eine größere
gemeinschaft der verweigerung der
schaeffler familie gegenüber dass mir
das auch geordnet will was das alles mit
sich bringt
diese ziemlich bewusstes nicht einfach
irgendeine vorstellung ist nicht mit
praktischen es zu wenn es zu ende wenn
sie oder sie haben einfach nicht so
mehrdimensional wieder sitzt lerne noch
eine andere bewohnerinnen bewohner
feuerwehrfamilie kann jetzt sagen wir
mal einen moment was für musik christoph
trummer gemacht das hat nämlich oyster
grundgesetz sind die neue platte heißt
familienalbum
welche spuren hinterlassen unsere eltern
bei uns verstehen wir sie erst als
erwachsener richtig und was bedeutet
familiengeschichte eigentlich diese
fragen treiben christoph trummer lange
bis er sie in sein musikalisches
schaffen ein baut sein neues werk
verlässt die klassische form eines
albums ist vielmehr eine sammlung aus
essays und songtexten so schildert er
die geschichte seiner früh verstorbenen
eltern
es sind liebevolle erzählungen aus
kleinen alltagsszenen die große und auch
unbequeme wahrheiten zutage fördern
[Musik]
aber ich glaube es ist glaube ich eine
liebevolle zugang
danke sehr wichtig
[Musik]
die idee
stehen
[Musik]
b
so
hc
wieder fluchte
[Musik]
und die fähre
b
vor revolution zu generation geht es ja
bewusst diesen entwicklung und
geschichte weitergeht möglichkeiten wie
zugeht und so und das game bietet aber
jährige tochter gewusst was ich oder wie
der wieder einmal bewusst machen was sie
ihre wieder mit sogar das glaubt ihr
spektrum zukunft daraus macht und
familie schützen seine zahlen das extrem
sichtbar wird von generation zu
generation die bilder im familienalbum
hat der illustrator andreaskirche gemalt
einige mutet nostalgisch an oder zeigen
nur sehr vage
das familienleben thomas album ist
ungeschminkte wahrheit und versöhnung in
einem
so wie familie eben ist
[Musik]
vater mutter kind so hat sie einst
ausgesehen die norm der familie
heutzutage ist es interessanter aber
auch anstrengender familie zu leben
welche bedeutung hat dieser mikrokosmos
noch für uns und welche schlüsse ziehen
wir aus dem loch down aus die familie so
richtig auf die probe gestellt wurde
aber auch zeigen konnte was sie denn
sein kann
auf zur nächsten runde nun werden wieder
kontakte beschränkt
für viele menschen bedeutet dass ein
rückzug eine konzentration auf die
familie
für manche der ultimative stresstest und
die zukunft ist ungewiss
maria teresa de es krise ist eine
erfahrene psychotherapeutin für familien
sie weiß dass die situation belastend
ist aber es gibt auch positive effekte
für viele familie das natürlich auch vor
einzelnen lied gehört die die erste
phase oder mein liebster punkt dann dazu
führt dass man sich mit ihm beschäftigt
ja dass nur nummern merken wir sind hier
gut wo eigentlich wenn es zu machen da
sind miteinander ins gespräch kommen
den stillstand als willkommene
entschleunigung erleben einem teil der
schweizer familien ist das wertes
schotter und im frühjahr gelungen
doch viele fühlen sich gestresster wenn
alles an einem ort stattfinden muss wenn
es weniger außenkontakte gibt worauf
kommt es an wenn es eng wird das bild
vom flugzeug immer ganz ganz wichtig im
zusammenhang mit familie und kind ja
also beides problem eine krise da ist
dann muss ich zuerst einmal werke dass
ich versucht stoffen als einfach sind
die person dann nur gefühlt und ich
glaube das war für mich ganz wichtige
botschaft die psychologin empfiehlt auf
sich zu achten sich gut zu organisieren
auch nach kurzfristigen zielen und
projekten zu suchen
die regisseurin andrea starker hat
während des showdowns die chance genutzt
und einen kurzfilm gedreht
für die collection lockdown der srg er
zeigt das leben damals im frühling mit
ihrem sohn und dessen freundin
ursachen für die selig sie haben mehr
kurven habe ich eine davon dass man aber
nicht gerne machen kann finde ich eine
andere beziehung zum ihm so niewerth
aufbaut als teenager ist es alle zu
einfach
sie werden unter anderem mit vier
familien auch die sorge um ihre mutter
spielt eine rolle im film wie viele
ältere menschen konnte diese über monate
ihrer familie nicht sehen diese
isolation zu vermeiden sieht andrea
stärker als große herausforderung für
die zeit die nun kommt eine einsamkeit
gilt als eines der größten risiken in
der korona zeit die not zu geraten
es geht darum weiter kontakte zu pflegen
im rahmen der möglichkeiten einen alltag
zu gestalten der uns psychisch gesund
bleiben lässt und sich wann immer
möglich in leichtigkeit zu üben
diese familie versucht für körperlichen
ausgleich zu sorgen
auch künstler und filmemacher thomas
hemmerling den shutdown filmisch
festgehalten
ein humorvoller blick auf den alltag in
der schule zu hause und jetzt gibt es
schon strategien für die zeit die kommt
zum letzten loch der xxl früher schrank
kaufte ich werde mit ihnen und hilflos
schwarzl und andere zirkuswoche und dort
mit mini familiäre konflikte auf wochen
erledigt für ein paar wochen planen
das klingt gut denn alles andere ist
ohnehin ungewiss
das jetzt fortsetzen
das geht so es dann wenn man damit
rechne also sich mehr angst das ist
sicher weniger klar was sich jetzt ja
ich glaube ich wirklich sagen womit
bezogen sind in einer phase wo man nur
so viel drüber grüßt hand was man nicht
wüsste
gefragt sind geduld und achtsamkeit
wertschätzung für die wichtigen menschen
im leben und strategien wie ängste und
befürchtungen nicht überhand nehmen
[Musik]
corona komfort und verluste oder frische
luft wie drei mitbewohnerinnen und
mitbewohnern einen partnershop gerät was
ist es für die gemeinschaft ist es
erwägen oder ist es eine wahlfamilie
familie natürlich zu stehen gesetzt für
euer andere ist beides mit anna lüth
aber es ist wie eine familie wohl in der
mitte zusammen
also ich seine musik und ihren töchtern
passend immer was wir beweggrund gibt es
eine gemeinschafts ziel ist es angst
vorm allein sie ist es ein garantiert
beim babysitter markets ist es nicht
wenn konventionelle familie aber was
sind eure motivation
wir präsentieren senioren generation und
somit mannschaft und ich habe mir gar
nicht dann ist vorstellbar auch jetzt
gerade so mit fried analytische innere
generationen so schön mini motivation
ist das mit großem garten und das hat in
über 120 kilometern zerlegen und glück
doch was heißt familie fast wie sie nun
reduziert möglich wann dann überhaupt
noch jetzt die familie umfasst 27 manche
regierung mit einer regelung kommen nach
gas aktuell macht am mittwoch glauben
wir dass
drei treffer das besprechen und
gottlosen machen gruppe
das ist kompliziert die einfachste
variante
ein thema dass fast alle familien zur
genüge keinen tick tock instagram und
üben auf jugendliche eine immense
anziehungskraft aus ja und diese
anziehungskraft die spürt auch die kunst
und sie will und kann sich ihr auch
nicht entziehen
das zeigt ein neues festival das heute
startet die dichte nord zürich dies sind
alles was wir haben so heißt diese
videoarbeit von roboters und jona maura
die beim digital art festival in zürich
gezeigt wird miley ist nicht die person
ein die digitale zeichensprache bestimmt
die mimik des menschen
längst hat die digitale welt den kunst
kosmos erreicht projektionen videos die
weiße spots künstler und künstlerinnen
bedienen sich digitaler mittel oder
nutzen das netz für ihre kunst dort
finden sie das material für ihre
künstlerische auseinandersetzung oder
nutzen gleich den virtuellen raum als
kunstraum doch die digitale kunst
fristet ein dasein in der nische kaum
ausstellungen für galerien wenig
interessant trotz der vielen bunten
bilder
warum ist das so wer ein aspekt ist
diese kunst mag das nicht weil die
digitale kunst ist natürlich nicht
verkäuflich algorithmen und kann man
sich an die wand hängen und dadurch das
digitale kunst und kunstmarkt und auch
für die traditionelle kunstwelt ausfällt
steht kein interesse die zu fördern
dem will die digital art zürich
entgegenwirken und zeigt 31 projekte die
das ganze spektrum digitaler kunst
beleuchtet darunter eine interaktive
installation des schweizer
medienkünstlers markley
in seiner arbeit entscheidet eine
software welche sequenzen aus sozialen
medien die unter bestimmten hashtags auf
ticker kursieren projiziert werden und
nutze profi und vor den texturen videos
wenn das neue super last exit tax dass
ich zum thema protest doch 7 ist der
hashtag sitz des bundes road regie zum
pay-tv die videos kontrastiert mattli
mit fragen wie sind normale menschen die
stars der zukunft oder wie wird die
nächste generation geschichten erzählen
linking trace die brasilianische
künstlerin bianca kury benutzt die
digitalen möglichkeiten anders
sie kombiniert sounds musik und video in
zürich zeigte eine arbeit die von der
zerstörung des regenwaldes erzählt vom
missbrauch der lokalen satanische musik
durch die rechtsextreme regierung des
brasilianischen präsidenten john a meine
erste politische botschaft richtet sich
an das ausland
brasilien ist nicht diese harmonische
vielfältige demokratie das offene
integrative ist nicht mehr dass
brasilien in der wir leben
stattdessen ist es an land das nur auf
sich selbst schaut und nicht mehr nach
draußen
die zweite botschaft dieser musik wird
politisch missbraucht indem wir diese
starken bilder entgegen setzen versuchen
wir zu zeigen wie diese musik zum
soundtrack von portoroz politik wurde
auch das künstlerkollektiv des novation
ort nutzten im digitalen raum für den
politischen diskurs
sie arbeiten an der schnittstelle von
digitaler kunst und forschung
hinterfragen die digitale welt in zürich
präsentieren sie experten gespräche über
eine gesellschaft die versucht die idee
des ewigen wachstums zu überwinden
in diesen ständigen drang nach
fortschritt und beschleunigung nach
wirtschaftswachstum wollen wir als
künstler des mit abstand betrachten und
eine reihe von projekten vorschlagen die
den stellenwert von technologien der
gesellschaft aufgreifen und untersuchen
wie innovation aus einer kritischen
perspektive betrachtet werden kann
digitale kunst ist so vielfältig wie
ihre technologischen möglichkeiten das
zeigt die digital art in zürich sie
nutzt nicht nur die vielzahl digitaler
techniken als werkzeug
sie schafft auch neue räume virtuellen
und provoziert unsere wahrnehmung wie in
diesem video auf wen trifft dieser
mensch auf sich selbst
auf eine digitale kopie und in welcher
welt eigentlich fragen über fragen
antworten gibt es bei der digital art in
zürich vielleicht
[Musik]
zu sehen
und jetzt zur aktuellen corona situation
der bundesrat hat heute entschieden
veranstaltungen mit mehr als 50 personen
werden verboten
die schweizer kulturinstitutionen sind
einmal mehr im ausnahmezustand wir haben
uns umgehört
das kosmos zürcher kulturstätte mit
gastronomie und kino unter einem dach
das foto basler kleinkunsttheater mit
mehreren bühnen
und das zeughaus kultur brieger mehr
sparten zentrum für die ganze region
drei institutionen eine herausforderung
wie überleben in zeiten die flexibilität
mehrbelastung und krisenresistenz
abverlangen
vom ersten lockdown hat monika holzers
zeughaus noch hilfsgelder zu gute
und schon sind die kulturhäuser weil es
wieder geschlossen und damit alle
veranstaltungen abgesagt
persönliche schlimmem einfach sehr viel
gemacht im vorfeld dass unser vermieter
und da ich das vor schwer so ein film
stützt sich das einfach so als nicht
systemrelevant stopp mit einer weiteren
verschärfung hat auch caroline rasser
gerechnet das foto erlitt einbußen von
rund 1,5 millionen franken
immerhin nebst staatliche unterstützung
konnte das haus auf seiner anhänger
zählen mit einem crowdfunding sammelte
es über 100.000 franken investiert in
eine neue lüftung fürs publikum sich so
dass mehr solidarität und der goodwill
spürten in der stadt dort nein
eigentlich im ganzen land dafür sorge
für uns schwieriger haben dass ihnen
ganz viel deutlich dass wir wiederkommen
dass man beruf machen und das ist eine
motivation die kommunität setzte alle
[Musik]
vom lockdown betroffen war auch der hg
soldat läpple dutzende von ausverkauften
vorstellungen mit 14 köpfigen ensemble
mussten verschoben oder abgesagt werden
wegen corona bedingter reduzierter
platzzahl klafft ein weiteres loch in
der kasse jetzt sieht man von den
reserven was mir natürlich auch extrem
hoffen und wirklich doof gewesen sind
dass meter schnee jetzt wieder hilft
gehen jetzt gut in form vorher mit
kurzarbeit oder ausfall entschädigung
das ist existenziell für eine
subventionierte betrieb wie unsere ohne
kurzarbeit ginge es nicht heißt es im
kosmos
denn kultur ist auf defizitär und wenn
wie zuletzt noch weniger publikum
erscheint schutzvorkehrungen aber
zusätzliche personalkosten verursachen
dann stehen einnahmen und ausgaben erst
recht in einem missverhältnis
nun brauche es einheitliche branchen
regeln die unwägbarkeiten seien schon
groß genug findet
geschäftsleitungsmitglied sarah breuer
wie können wir damit um dass im moment
sämtliche kultur voraus stetige
aufgezeigt werde reduziert werde das die
soziale interaktion zwischen man
schwankt wird das ist ja bis wo es noch
lange beschäftigt und wir finden es
gefährlich und das ganze im keim
erstickt
gleichzeitig sei das verständnis für
maßnahmen gegeben so monika holziger sie
stößt sich jedoch daran wenn die politik
kultur als reinen spaß faktor ab tut
sich geordnet sind wir jetzt wichtig und
sozialgeld und auseinandersetzung mit
themen wie jetzt aktuell sind was was
passiert wie die ich das macht das minus
mit und da hat kultur ein wichtiger
beitrag im schnitt einfach nur mal so
ein bisschen aber bewegungen schon
anrufe
[Musik]
darunter bei mir braune kiste ich sag
mir die letzte untersuchen ob die leute
wissen das geschafft ende ist absehbar
zyklischen krank skulptur la paz
momentan aber inneren kampfes mit
konzert ja schwierig schwierig wird viel
abgeseiht und und man schaue dann
dilemma halt selber spiele lohnt sich
wirtschaftlich überhaupt so ist es
verantwortbar gesundheitlich das ist
eine schwierige situation
[Musik]
versteht mich
das war unser besuch bei einer ganz und
gar ungewöhnlichen familie und dieses
projekt das sieht ja wirklich nach einer
soliden basis aus um über die kommenden
schwierigen monate zu kommen
wenn wir uns das nächste mal wieder
sehen dann haben die usa bereits gewählt
und das wird natürlich auch bei uns ein
thema sein
gleich jetzt fordert der report der
markt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
swisslos